i
i appreciate that you are sporting the
hat
that's my purge forever hat is it i've
uh
you know when i was doing my research i
was looking at your socials and noticed
it's it's quite the popular attire for
you right now
that hat this hat is a winner i got it i
think i told you i think i said it on
um on twitter i got it at walgreens and
it's really a winner i got one in red
and one in blue
i mean it's the best purchase i've ever
made i think it costs four dollars
it feels also just you know the right
energy for this summer as we joyously
make our way back out into public
that's what i feel like too it just
really it really clicks for me every day
every day i put it on i feel better good
well it is nice to see you we are not in
public at the
moment but i'm sure we'll have an
in-person interview before long
um um good i'm looking forward to it
likewise
what is to jump off of that a little bit
how did you land on feeling secure in
this
date for release you know these always
did well in the july area because of the
sort of patriotic themes in there
patriotic but uh at what point did you
know that you were going to be okay to
move forward with this release date
um god i guess i would say
we knew we would be okay after the quiet
place opened i felt like
i felt like uh we would be okay but
until then you know it was anybody's
guess
that's very recent um yeah have you
something i've been noticing
specifically in horror is that because
so many
projects were shelved over the last year
to wait for theatrical
how complicated has it been finding the
right place
to now release your films and theaters
as
it's especially as you look towards
halloween with all the horror that's
trying to catch up
where did were you able to find space
and how did you approach that
well it's it's very complicated it's
just incredibly crowded all these movies
have been
have been uh like you know piling up and
now they're all coming out they're
coming out too close together
um i don't know maybe that's a good
thing because people have more the
consumer has a lot more choice so
we kind of we've kind of in danger of
teaching people never to go out to the
movies again
so hopefully a wider array of choice
we'll encourage people to
remember the movie going habit for our
movies definitely
our movies can't be experienced
in you know the experience of seeing one
of our movies at home is just not the
same as seeing our movies in the theater
at all i've really come to appreciate
that more than ever before have over the
past uh
18 months um but it's very busy it's a
very busy corridor it's going to be very
busy for
for really the next eight to 12 months
um
and uh you know it's it's complicated
now movies aren't staying in theaters as
long
so that gives more room um
um but uh but uh but it's it's it's all
the business is
all you know turned around it's on its
end it's
kind of been on its head and it's gonna
be all kind of turned around
i think really for that in that part
probably longer one to two years before
it
it really settles back into some sort of
it's never it's not going to be what it
was but into some sort of pattern
that we can actually say okay this is
the business now it's just we don't it's
too
drunk it's too soon to draw a conclusion
the movie business is back
it's not back only horror movies work
only superhero movies work
nothing works you know it's too soon to
say
and it's really going to be too soon to
say i think for a couple of years
in a theoretical world had that
a quiet place to launch not gone so well
were you guys ready to pull back or were
you fully committed to going back to
theaters at this date
uh i i i don't want to pin it so much to
quiet place too if it hadn't worked in a
bunch of
the the few movies after if if movies
chose if people weren't going
you know it's a good question you can
pivot now
four or five weeks out i get you know
they're people
they're different things you could do
the movie could have been made available
on pivot at the same time as it opened
theatrically like that's one thing we
could have done
they're definitely things that we could
have done to adjust
if it looked like the actual marketplace
was just in shambles
but i'm very glad we didn't have to do
that yeah but
um you touched on something that
i wanted to ask about a little later but
since it came up now you you have been
very open over the years that theatrical
is a huge
part of the profitability specifically
of your horror projects
um how were you able to navigate the
last 18 months and what steps did you
take
to you know stay in decent shape when
that was pretty much removed from the
equation
the movie business it it it has a long
tail
so really we're we're going to feel
really this year
funnily enough and next year or more
than like so when
we so we were we were you know living
off the invisible man through covid
but the but the problem is we didn't
have anything after
that so now is actually the trick your
time and and just to answer the way that
i i guess to answer your questions the
way we've been mitigating that is doing
um a lot more work in tv and doing
streaming movies
which we did all through the pandemic
and we're continuing to do
so we're trying to um uh we're
we're not trying to we're making money
in different ways the other question i
have sort of about the delay
specifically relating to the forever
purge is this
um you know was written and completed
so long ago and it is
so um tied up in the state of our nation
were you guys at all concerned that it
would feel
out of date by the time it finally hit
in 2021 and then the
sort of inverse of that is uh
after january 6 were you like oh maybe a
little
too timely too touchy
um both of those those things that you
said are true
but you can't it's out of my control i
i've learned in my business
not to be not to try to try and not be
concerned about things you can't control
so there was nothing i could do about
either one of those events you never
know
the timing of a movie is is uh
it can be great or it can be terrible
i've lived i've lived through both
but there's not a lot you can do so i i
try and focus on other things but uh
but but uh but luckily luckily i'm uh
i have the ability to do that but if i
weren't able to do that i would be
worried but i try not to think about it
because
there's really nothing i can do either
way and by the way stuff
changes so fast now you know what what's
a problem three months ago is not a
problem in three months and what's
coming in three months you don't know
so i try not to think about it but all
of those things are
can be impediments to the to
the forever purge or any movie you know
the current events affect our
affect viewing habits of people by
tremendously i had to go double check
like my
my facts go fact check if you would like
to use the correct term
uh because it felt once again and
your your writer james demonico seems to
keep doing this
like uh slightly prophetic i was like
did they really finish this
in 2020 uh
i don't know if i have a specific
question about that i will just say that
demonico is becoming something of a sort
of like horror schlock profit and
it's freaking me out man it's bizarre i
mean it's totally with the movie i
swear on everyone you know in my life
the movie was finished the script was
finished everything was done
way before january i mean they look like
they're wearing purge masks i mean it's
so crazy
and you know the election you know he's
done it three or four times like i don't
know he sees the future i agree with you
it's very scary and very creepy
but it's true you know he hasn't he we
don't like go reshoot the movies after
things happen
in fact you can be you can also you can
also to your point you can also be too
close to what's happening so
you know we're not i don't think we're
really specifically trying to do that
you don't want the purge movies to
predict the future that's that's not a
good future
let's hope let's hope it's it's always
going to be slightly
in allegorical prediction not a little
yes exactly
exactly exactly uh
i at a certain point part of me is like
he should he should stop writing such
bad things he should write a really
happy
fantasy and see if that comes comes to
fact i would like to is he
what's he doing here let's put some
positivity out there
totally totally i'm
with the purge when this was first you
know sort of announced and talked about
in press uh it was pretty
like framed as the final installment and
that framing seems to have
dissipated a bit as it's come to its
release
do you guys still consider it the final
purge do you think
now that there's because yeah i can shed
some light on that james and i james and
i are
endless in a huge fight about it not a
real fight but
but uh but he doesn't want to do any
more but i
definitely do want to do more um and i'm
very i'm very persuasive so uh so
i would bet on i would bet on me but uh
but so far
he's still saying this is the last one
but i'm trying to talk him into some
more so that's why it's
it's murky but so so we don't i you know
who knows
currently right now this is the last
this is the last purge
gotcha maybe he's afraid he's he's
telling the future
well i think he's spent a lot you know
he obviously spends a lot more time
inside the purge than i do writing the
movies up of course
i think it's hard to live inside the
purge he's been living in it for seven
years i think it's
my heart goes out to him i think it's
not easy absolutely uh when we
were talking for the purge anarchy many
years ago
which was you know the one where you
really opened it out into the world took
it to the streets
we were kind of joking around about all
the infinite possibilities of where this
could
go and it like you've gone to a lot of
those
possibilities do you think that there is
i will use a very goofy example but just
to get the point across you know people
joked for years
about fast and furious going to space
and now
they did do you think there's a cap to
how big those ideas can get
no you mean can you jump the shark for
sure i mean you could jump the shark and
anything you could you could jump the
shark in uh
in purge movies i'm watching a show on
tv called with honor which i really
liked but they jumped the shark the
beginning
the end of the beginning either the end
of season the end of the
sixth episode of the beginning of the
seven episode it is so obvious
that they blew it i don't know what
happened in the writers room but that's
all
that i i was very aware that they did it
on that show
and um you suddenly get much less
interested in it i hope we never do it
on the purge but it's a it's a risk of
course
i mean to a certain extent i would think
that
your your restraint when it comes to
budget and the way you've held to that
all these years
prevents a certain measure of that is
that
does that feel true i think that's a
very i think that's a great point
that if you have endless money to spend
the
chances of jumping the shark are greatly
increased
i think that's very i think that's very
very accurate you know it's one of the
reasons i like working
on tight budgets because it forces the
directors to use different tools to tell
their stories
than things that cost a lot of money um
because i think
by their very nature things that cost a
lot of money
are like band-aids storytelling like you
can't think of a
good way to resolve a problem so you you
know
whatever you use a bunch of cgi and do
something set piece
and that doesn't advance your story it
doesn't it doesn't really solve your
problem
it just distracts the viewer from the
problem but it doesn't solve it
and i think i think keeping budgets
tight
um makes our directors better problem
solvers and less likely to do what
you're talking about
going back a little bit to those uh
political themes
and whether or not they're too intense
and too timely
um you seem
i would say maybe unperturbed by the
blowback your films can get in that
regard
and i find that especially impressive
after what happened
with the hunt uh do you ever get
panic about that are you always
internally as unflustered by
what can you know especially uh in our
current times on social media how far
these things can escalate uh i
i'm only flustered if it hurts the movie
i'm not flustered by anything else the
hunt it destroyed this terrific movie
all these people worked so hard on this
movie craig's oval
the cast uh damon lindelof you know is
one of the great
he's one of the great you know artists
of our time
they made something spectacular and and
and it was wrecked by people
talking about a movie that they hadn't
seen particularly the pr
you know particularly a reporter and
that
i was incredibly upset about because no
one saw the movie
as a result and i think it was a
terrific movie i
it's it's it's a movie i'm incredibly
proud of and it's the biggest
um you know it sounds like i have a chip
in my shoulder i do it's the biggest
sore spot i have
of any movie or show we've ever done is
the fact that
you know that movie was taken away from
the public um
for for for not a good or a bad reason a
reason that didn't exist
and so and so that really bothers me
but you know i had threats to my life uh
and my family's life during the movie uh
but you can't be when you're doing what
i'm doing you know you can't you can you
if i got so wrapped up in that i just
have to quit what i'm doing you know
we're we're storytellers we tell stories
they don't make everyone happy all the
time
but that's easier to stomach what's hard
to stomach is that particular one
you know you touched a nerve because
people were talking about a movie that
they hadn't seen and making assumptions
about it that didn't exist
and they succeeded in in destroying the
performance of the movie
yeah well it was uh that was actually
the last
movie i saw in theaters before lockdown
wow wow yeah well you were one of the
few very few people saw that movie at
the theater
and when we were opening in in september
it was gonna it was it was opening to be
a
we know we were tracking to be a big hit
movie um which
financially is i financially i could
honestly i don't care
at this point but a big hit movie
meaning it would have
had a cultural impact and what i'm you
know what
what gets me up in the morning is that
is when our movies
you know impact the culture in some way
get out did
to a lesser extent invisible man did um
the purge movies do to a certain degree
um
and that movie was on the road to doing
that too and when that was pulled away
pulled out from under me um it was
it was uh it was it was extremely
upsetting
it's also this is much more micro uh but
it also kind of
buried one of what i consider the most
interesting film performances
in recent memory from betty gilfin i'm
not sure i've
ever seen anyone approach a role the way
she does with that betty gilpin
you know that that's that's actually the
best example damon lindelof he's
got a great you know his career uh he
doesn't need any help
neither does craig zobel at this point
betty gilpin was going to be
i'm a huge movie star off that movie and
now she
she she she should be a movie star she's
incredible
i'm going to do another movie with her i
think she still will become a movie star
she will be in something that will
connect with audiences
but had that movie been released in the
fall she already would be a huge movie
star and that
that was taken away from her yeah that
chase
i get you i did have another
purge specific question which is i i
really enjoyed the purge series but it
clearly didn't
connect and find the longevity of the
film franchise
what do you think went wrong there or if
nothing went wrong why do you think it
succeeds
more in the film format i'm very glad
that we did it
i really like the series it really
wasn't taken off
the air for a problem by the way
we've done plenty of things that um
haven't worked
like the hunt for instance so i'm not
i'm not i'm very if something doesn't
work i have no problem issues saying it
the ratings were good not great there
was internal
this is um um what's exciting and
frustrating and crazy about our business
there was
internal agenda stuff going on
at uh at usa at the time and so
where they really needed this show when
they ordered it they didn't really want
the show
um for the third season for reasons
having other to do with
how the performance of it was now listen
if it had been
wildly a huge hit they would have made
room for it but we were on the bubble
and they took it off the air as a result
of being on the bobble
um
so the other question though
is whether or not having it on the air
actually
took away from the movies the
performance of the movies
and i don't know the answer to that it
might have you know i don't know the
answer to that so i
it wasn't like i was uh i didn't feel
the same way about
the purge coming off the air that i did
about the hunt you know i wish it stayed
on but
part of me was like well if it might
have i thought the
show would actually help the movies that
did not happen
it definitely didn't happen i don't it
was either neutral or hurt
but it didn't help it um i think people
i think i think i think purging once a
year might have been enough for people
fair enough uh coming off of that
experience do you feel
any differently about the idea generally
of spin-off shows from your films
yeah i do i don't i'm not so enamored
with the idea of
putting a series on tv at the same time
there's a movie
in the middle of a movie franchise
before the purge
happened if you would pitch me like
let's put a paranormal a paranormal
activity tv show on me i don't know what
the hell that would be
but a paranormal activity tv show on the
year um
[Music]
i would have been more inclined to say
yes whereas now i'd be more inclined to
say we should wait till the movie is
done
which is what everyone has always done i
thought i could i thought it might be
different now and i'll
i think i probably i probably was wrong
about that
well when it comes to something like um
paranormal i was gonna ask you if you
guys had reached the point
where you were considering rebooting
your own
ip and there was a report that
paranormal is being
rebooted or retooled with will eubank
and christopher landon
um so i it seems you guys have
reached the point yeah we we did the
it's movies done
wow yeah yeah we did we did we did it
so what was how did you reach the
conclusion that it was time to rather
than just continue down the same
mythology
revamp the franchise uh
uh i i i really thought that the only
way
paramount wanted to continue paranormal
activity i probably would have left it
alone so they wanted to continue it
but i thought if they were going to
continue it um
uh you gotta just you you
it was it was tired there was no way to
kind of continue
the road that we'd bid down i don't
remember when the last movie came out
four or five years ago
uh so so i really encouraged
all the creative people involved to try
and think of something new
um there are people now who
you know were three years old the movie
a lot of the people who were gonna go
see the new paranormal activity were
three years old
when the first paranormal activity even
came out so they don't even know from
those older movies
and uh you know i thought if you're
gonna redo it you better really redo it
not
try and extend what we had done uh you
know all those years ago
sure do you consider that
a let's say a test balloon for the idea
of reboot
rebooting your own ip is that something
you're working on more
broadly as a part of your no i could no
no i considered i considered halloween
that you know i said halloween there was
a great movie
40 years ago and then there were a bunch
of not so great movies
um and i and i that was the challenge of
like how can we
put a new spin on halloween that'll make
it compelling and interesting and
relevant to today
but still connected enough to that first
movie so i i saw that as much more an
experiment than
than paranormal activity actually
it there was okay so obviously halloween
and you've
you've generally given bigger budgets to
your
your studio collaborations as well as
your sequels
but as you move into you guys have a
handful of
recognizable stephen king films in the
works with fire starter and christine
do those types of projects challenge
that uh that restraint that you built
your
your your model off of in a different
way
yeah when you have known ip you can't
get away with 6 or seven million dollars
it's much harder i should say you know
lee 1l did it with the invisible man but
it it
it's much harder and and so
so but i still think if you look at the
average price of a studio movie now
which is
between 60 and 70 million dollars we're
still way below that
even at 15 or 20 million bucks we're
still way way below that and i i like i
said
earlier in the interview you know i i
think i think lower budgets lead to
better movies
and so how low budget obviously depends
if it's an original we can still do them
for
five six seven million dollars if
there's existing ip
you're putting more hurdles in front of
the filmmaker so it's just too hard to
say the filmmaker
it you know your halloween it's got to
be you've got it
yeah jamie lee curtis and this and that
and everything else and then you have to
do it for
nothing you have to give the filmmaker a
little bit more resources but i still
give the filmmakers
you know much less resources than i
think ideally they would like
um which they're mad about going into it
but coming out of it i think oftentimes
they feel like there was a reason for it
one that stands out to me in particular
is working with brian fuller who is
known for his
uh incredible visuals and and production
value how did you guys strike the
balance in your conversations of
agreeing on
a sort of you know lower
higher budget for you may be lower than
what he might be used to
you know i the conversation i had with
him is is kind of the conversation i
have
with similar to most filmmakers which is
this is because it sounded a little
contradictory to what i said before but
i'm going to say it anyway
you can't when you first start out it's
it's not fair i think to the filmmaker
or the director to have them really
write to a budget i just say write
try and keep the budget in mind when you
write but write a great story
when we get a great script and a great
story then
the second phase of of how we attack
making a movie is
we say to the director hey you know this
scene takes place in the statue of
liberty could it take place instead you
know
at a [ __ ] newsstand or something you
know can you we we go
through the script and 50 of the time
the filmmaker says no way you're out of
your mind at 50 of the time the
filmmaker says yeah i don't really care
i didn't think about that when i was
writing it i just you know that's fine
and that's how we whittle it down it's
too
hard to start out with brian fuller and
then say
hey i'm so excited about christine now
make sure you write something we can
shoot for cheap
it's not it's not a good way to start up
a relationship
but everyone knows when we started with
david gordon green on halloween he knew
and he wrote and then after he wrote we
we
[Music]
worked on it to get it to a place where
we could make it for whatever we made it
for
12 million or 14 million dollars you
also of course you always have that
you know sort of ace in your pocket
which is the creative control for the
filmmaker
on another talent angle you were able to
get ryan gosling for wolfman and he's
become
very selective about the projects he
picks over recent years
he makes less and less it seems like so
what were the conversations like
that convinced him to come on board that
project
you know that actually um
he is the one who approached universal
he really
um connected with that character
and he actually it's very unusual but he
actually before i was even involved in
the movie he approached universal and
said i want to be the wolf man
and i really want to make a movie about
i want to make a new wolf man movie and
i want to play the wolf man
and and for a variety of reasons you'll
have to ask him on that but for a
variety of reasons he really connected
with that character that he wanted to do
it
so that's how that's how that happened
that's interesting so then does
universal come to you
and you bring leonel into the equation
on that movie that's exactly what
happened yes yes
yes exactly yeah yeah i'm
fine i know i've interviewed you enough
to know better than to push further on
details on a movie you're still
developing
well thank god i appreciate you letting
me off the hook
i'm very curious about that one i will
say
one more question when those
introductions happened
did it seem that ryan gosling and luanne
were on the same page with the approach
or did you guys really have to hash that
out
the approach um
sorry it's just a complicated it's not
it's not an easy easy
neither you know they weren't on the
same page they weren't on different
pages they weren't on the same page
um um ryan
because and it's it's it's unusual that
an actor would come
you know elizabeth moss didn't go to
universal saying i want to be obviously
i want to be in the invisible band movie
you know this is
unusual to your which your reaction
makes sense
so ryan has a very specific idea about
about what the what he wants the
character to be
and the character has to fit in the plot
of a scary
movie right and so that makes for a very
fertile
conversation about how are we going to
do this so
so there was so ryan and it was not
simple it wasn't like
lee was like oh ryan's playing the wolf
man i know exactly what this is going to
be
so there were a bunch of very very long
conversations to start to break out
what what the actual story would be and
those conversations are ongoing
makes sense um
another thing you're doing that is you
know a little bit off course for you
is with insidious five you've really
always been very clear that your model
thrives because you work with
established filmmakers and obviously
patrick wilson is not new to the
industry he is a very known presence and
you have worked with him many times
but it is his first time directing so
what gave you the confidence to hand
the the keys over to one of your biggest
franchises to a first-time director
well we've done that a lot with i i
really say it's experience on set
i mean jordan peele was a first-time
director joel edgerton who did the gift
was a first-time director
so so i'm using that term you know
loosely meaning what i what i'm what i'm
look what i'm
what i'm reluctant to do we work with a
lot
of very young first-time directors in
our television company we make
movies for amazon we made eight movies
for epics a lot of those directors are
from we made
24 movies for hulu a lot of those are
first and second time directors
so i don't have an aversion to working
with first or second young first or
second time directors
on our specifically low budget
horror movies um i i have an aversion to
working with
with with inexperienced
you know people on set um um i wouldn't
say i would never do it but
but i think it's i i to go back to the
earlier point that i was making
in order to be able to make a terrific
low-budget movie
you have to have enough experience to
know what's worth spending money on and
what isn't
and if you're a first-time director who
hasn't spent a lot of time on set
it's understandably very hard to know
that so so for me
patrick really fits into the joel
edgerton jordan peel
category um which is very different than
than someone just out of film school
makes sense was that a situation
where he came to you and said i want to
do this was that's
a conversation you'd had for a while as
a potential
um i'm not sure of the actual answer
that question but
i think it was his idea i don't think we
approached him i think
it was his idea and i left at the idea
um when it when when someone who worked
for me told me that patrick
i think that's how it happened i think
he mentioned someone who works for me i
said that's
great we should do it i was very very
enthusiastic about it but i do think
he he brought it up first kind of a
goofy question but i'm going to ask it
because i've thought about it a long
time
uh you guys are working more with the
universal monsters
have you had any conversations or is
there any interest in eventually getting
to like an abbott and costello type
approach reframing the classic monsters
through this more comedic approach
uh uh there has been zero conversation
about it but i would now rule it but
but i think i think um
by the way it's not up to me i don't you
know i'm not in charge of the monsters
i'm doing a couple monster movies you
know that's it's universal who's who's
managing and
running the the the monster verse or
whatever whatever it's being called
um my opinion about it is
i think you need to um i think it
you can't just have the you know you
need to have
five more movies like the invisible man
before you can start playing with
it and i think you really need to we you
know
uh a werewolf movie dracula you know i
think you really need to have a handful
of
really solid great movies about these
monsters that are relevant to 2021 that
people love
before you start getting getting clever
but like i said it's not it's not my
decision right all right i have one more
of the goofier type along those lines
i know there is a lot of trash talk
flung at this one but i'm a huge fan
of halloween three and i always thought
the idea of the anthological approach to
horror stories
was really quite brilliant you guys
obviously have your michael myers
trilogy in the work
but has that conversation come up is
that of interest
at all that approach to the legacy of
halloween
not to me but like i said my my
shepherding of halloween
my shepherding is uh hopefully not but
but
currently it's done after the three
movies so you'll have to ask my uh my
partner in crime malek akkad who uh
who will do halloween from from now till
the end of the time
and you know he he may do that but uh
but uh
but not for me too too hard well no i
mean i won't go into it but but i
wouldn't do that with halloween
dang it sorry freaking disappointing
see that's why you got to be tough some
fans are happy some are sad you just
gotta hold your ground
um and there was one more thing i wanted
to touch on with you because
over the years throughout our interviews
we have often discussed
your belief that the uh the distribution
window would inevitably collapse
that appears to have finally fully
happened i was right wasn't i
you sure were i don't know if you could
have predicted it would have happened in
the way it did
uh your your stocks must be really
healthy
but uh now is that it
now that it has happened how does it
adjust your your strategy like it feels
like you probably were pretty prepared
for it being one of the people crying
that it was inevitable
but do you have to be even more
mercenary now with what gets a
a theatrical yes you do yeah what gets a
theatrical
is is the it's narrower and narrower
narrower how how a theatrical release is
defined what gets into a theater
um and like i said there's no
i i i i it's two different things i
don't know
i don't want you know the windows
collapsing are not good for the
entertainment business they're not good
for the movie business they're not
really
they're not even really that good for
the consumer but i
knew it was going to happen um and it
did happen and
and we have to live with it you know you
can't just stick your head in the ground
and hope these things aren't going to
happen you're making black and white
movies you can't just hope they're never
going to invent color
eventually they're going to invent color
no matter how much you might like black
and white
uh it's going to be a thing of the past
um
windows are not yet quite the thing of
the past but they're close
and at warner brothers they certainly
are um and
uh and and so that makes the what
qualifies as theatrical it's just harder
it's harder to make a movie that really
qualifies and feels like a theatrical
movie
um but uh but uh
but it's still possible still possible
and there's still there's still some
semblance of small you know three or
four week windows there's still a small
window left
so we'll see we'll see and you've always
like
been open that you decided that through
testing
but now if you have to be even stricter
you know
in addition to how a film plays for the
audience
are there other factors that now decide
if it's if it's a theatrical
yeah sadly you know the marketability of
a movie is always very important it's
now
even more important the the way a film
is marketed for theatrical release is
very different than the way it's
marketed for a streaming
release and um and you have to be able
to
market a movie uh with one
with with with with a very specific
spot or a very specific with a very
specific
message that reaches a very very broad
number you can't tailor the advertising
yet
for a theatrical movie in the way that
you can for a streaming
movie and so that means that you have to
have a concept that can kind of fit into
a
15 or 30 second spot and that was always
true but it's way more true now
um which is uh which is unfortunate but
it's the world we live in
right on well i am out of time with you
i have about a billion more questions
prepared so hopefully i'll talk
to you again soon thank you so much for
your time
thank you goodness good to see you guys